I have to get to the truth of what
happened that night
I am for truth no matter who tells it
I'm for justice no matter who it's for
or against 18 years ten months twenty
four days that's how long
Warren cave has sat in prison for the
murder of Jeff Berman I helped seal
Warren's fate with a series of articles
but is there an innocent man in prison
and did I need that charge
[Music]
portrayed me as a privileged psychopath
now I live in the house for a minute
breathe to lie and I could smell yours
before you even started talking how
could a mother and two daughters sleep
through such a violent encounter and
they never recovered the murder weapon
my UID is even where I can make your
life miserable in here there is a
monster inside every one of us you
terrified me what about you what's in
there we're playing with people's lives
are you ready for the consequences you
think all the secrets cannot do in the
trap
you tell Parnell back away you messed
with a family you have no idea what I've
done for my daughter's families they
take care of each other
[Music]
I have to get to the truth of what
happened
people get their show
[Music]
you
you